I love I love your money I love my name
I don't care if that's vain because I
spent a lot of time hating me
our names are powerful literally our
brains have a unique reaction to the
sound of our names sometimes even while
sedated but many students have their
names mispronounced or disregarded every
day in school so what impact does that
have on their education and what can
educators do my name is a genus Lilia -
it's actually make bust knock miss Botz
Nick V bond through the embarrassing
minute the moment when there's a pause
and you know it's because of you I
remember just being like oh that must be
me especially if they said David
everyone laughs I learned pretty quickly
that it was easier to just go buy a J
which is something that I quite honestly
regret doing now in 2012 researchers dr.
Rita Coley and dr. Daniel salabhasana
published a study called teachers please
learn our names racial microaggressions
in the K through 12 classroom here's dr.
Coley so it takes a lot for a first
grader to say to their teacher excuse me
you pronounce my name this way but it's
actually this way and it matters to me
in fact it takes a lot for a student of
any age the first time I ever tried to
confront a professor was actually last
semester and it wasn't really a good
experience some professors just don't
even ask they're just like can I call
you by the same she mispronounced my
name and asked me if he can call me
something else regardless of like
whether we want to be called a certain
way or not
it's an elder person who has a phd and
this and that
later on I felt like it was my
responsibility to actually email her and
tell her that professor I get that it's
the first day of class but you don't you
you don't even have the right to ask me
if you can call me something else
she later on apologizes but it's only
because we push the conversation forward
so what is the big deal if you can't
understand my name how can you
understand me
a microaggression is a subtle form of
discrimination that can occur
intentionally or unintentionally and it
can include telling a student their name
is too hard to say where central vantage
point dr. Koh Lee's research underscores
that a person's name is their entrance
point to the world so what happens when
those names are mispronounced
disregarded or even mocked there's
actually a term for the unintended
lessons kids learn in school things that
live between the lines and in hallways
and in roll call there's a lot that we
impart onto our students are on each
other that is complete like subtext
right we don't say it out loud but
afraid
al-jawhara al-thani is the head of
educational and community programs at
cathode foundation her work focuses on
hidden curriculum and how to fix it I
was in a class once a sixth grade
all-boys English class and it was like
15 minutes quiet reading time I was
sitting at the back of the class at one
point the boy puts his hand up and asks
the teacher he's like sir I have a
question he goes yeah he goes are they
all white you think kids don't register
it registers there are decades worth of
studies examining how curriculum
sometimes the world over is primarily
Eurocentric male and upper class with
names to match
it registers but the curriculum is not
always something that's up to a teacher
themselves learning names on the other
hand is you're sitting in the back row
in a lecture at 200 students meeting on
your phone you're gonna get me calling
you by name what are you doing professor
Susan Dunn has been teaching at
Northwestern University and Cutler for
over a decade her undergrad experience
at a liberal arts college with small
classes influenced her decision to
memorize the names of every student in
her classes wherever she teaches even in
the 200-person lectures for me teaching
is about a lot more than just
transmission of knowledge it's about the
growth and development of human beings
and so I can be far more effective in
doing that if I have at least a
recognition of know the identity of
people know their names know a little
bit of something about them even in a
large class that they know when they
walk in and I say hi and use their name
then I really know who they are when I
hear someone say my name correctly I'd
be like oh my god finally this person
they know how to say my name I think in
our increasingly globalized world where
we have people from all sorts of walks
of life interacting that the idea that
we're gonna mispronounce each other's
names is pretty much a given and so the
question and the challenge is to do as
much as we can to figure out how to
embrace each other which sometimes
starts with simply taking the time and
effort to figure out how to greet each
other properly or we're not asking
teachers to I'll be able to say
everybody's name correctly the second a
absolute the door but I think there's a
difference between imposing that oh your
name is hard to say versus I haven't
learned how to say anything like this
yet but I'm working on it because you're
important and your name is important and
I want to honor that in my classroom
what working on it looks like in
practice might be different for every
educator what's key is allowing teachers
the room to be students in this - we
flip this
and we we think about the expectation
for students to learn lots of new things
all at the same time and we encourage
them to sail and we encourage them to
keep trying and we encourage them I
think that like vulnerability that we
expect of students should be the same
expectation that we have of our teachers
like they they aren't the holders of all
knowledge we know that we know that
they're human what do I tell my younger
self I would tell her to be proud that
you have a unique name the fact that you
have such unique name doesn't make you
stand out a negative way but instead it
makes you shine know that that's like
nything embarrassing it's gonna take
time but you will understand how
important your name is actually and how
your parents did not name you just for
the sake of naming someone I would tell
my younger self to learn about the
significance of your name and call that
teacher out when they mispronounced your
name I will probably just take my
younger self by the shoulders look them
dead in the eye and tell him your name
means he who wins the struggle and it'll
be a prophecy if you let it be